show that when you take 10 inverse of X
and 10 inverse of 1 over X what do you
get well this is the finest theater
we've just shown that this is PI on 2
minus theta okay so that's where you get
your pie on to as required because the
thing is canceled okay last little piece
it says use the fact that 10 your mouse
is odd to find out what happens when you
don't think about this anymore when you
go for X is less than zero okay go
exercise easier how do we approach this
how to approach it it's not that
complicated if you think about the way
all this is going to work ten inverses
all is odd right so what does that mean
about this is also on on what grounds
would you I'll do that inside functions
on outside functions on so the whole lot
is on okay so that means that in order
to consider what's happening to this
thing when x is less than zero right you
can slap minus signs on everything you
can say what's happening to this guy
right negative and this is going to 10
about negative x okay what's gonna be
happening to him well because we just
demonstrated that these are both bored
okay that's going to be negative tan and
that's going to be sorry negative 10 of
the reciprocal okay because they're both
odd i can take the minus signs out as 10
inverse X and
here in verse 1 on X are odd okay now
what's this thing equal to take your
factor of minus one out and then you've
got what you've showed in Part C then
right it's negative pound so therefore
what does know or am I looking what does
this graph y equals this what would it
look like for all values of x stairs
ready what would it look like what's it
equal to 0 when x equals 0 I'm defined
because you have a division by zero
there okay but the x is positive right
you've got round two okay for X is
negative you've got negative PI over 2
and guess what I know it's we don't
usually think about this way but that
that is an odd function because the sum
of 21 functions will be another up
function so there you go